hallo deutsch schule wörter mit mehreren
bedeutungen das schloss
das schloss
das schloss für mein fahrrad das schloss
für mein fahrrad das schloss für die
prinzessin das schloss für die
prinzessin das fahrrad mit dem schloss
anschließen das fahrrad mit dem schloss
anschließen das schloss mit der kamera
fotografieren das schloss mit der kamera
fotografieren
ich schließe das fahrrad mit dem schloss
an ich schließe das fahrrad mit dem
schloss an ich fotografiere das schloss
mit der kamera ich fotografiere das
schloss mit der kamera die bank die bank
die bank zum sitzen die bank zum sitzen
die bank für das geld die bank für das
geld auf der bank sitzen auf der bank
sitzen
geldabheben bei der bank geld abheben
bei der bank ich sitze auf der bank
ich sitze auf der bank
ich hebe geld ab bei der bank ich hebe
geld ab bei der bank die birne die birne
die birne zum essen die birne zum essen
die birne für das licht die birne für
das licht die birne ist ein obst die
birne ist ein obst die birne macht das
licht die birne macht das licht das baby
ist eine birne
das baby ist eine birne die birne macht
das licht in der lampe die birne macht
das licht in der lampe die karte
die karte die karte für die navigation
die karte für die navigation die karte
zum spielen die karte zum spielen
der ort ist auf der karte
poker spielen mit den karten poker
spielen mit den karten
für die navigation benutze ich die karte
wir spielen poker mit den karten
wir spielen poker mit den karten die
maus die maus die maus für den computer
die maus für den computer die maus ist
ein tier
die maus ist ein tier die maus benutzen
die maus benutzen die maus rennt schnell
die maus rennt schnee ich benutze die
maus am computer ich benutze die maus am
computer die maus rennt schnell zum käse
die maus rennt schnell zum käse die
fliege die fliege die fliege ist ein
insekt die fliege ist ein insekt die
fliege für den mann
die fliege für den mann
die fliege fliegt die fliege fliegt eine
schwarze fliege für den mann eine
schwarze fliege für den mann
die fliege fliegt durch das büro die
fliege fliegt durch das büro der mann
trägt eine schwarze fliege der mann
trägt eine schwarze fliege die note die
note die note in der schule die note in
der schule die noten in der musik die
noten in der musik eine gute note im
deutsch test eine gute note im deutsch
test die note klingt schön die note
klingt schön
ich habe eine gute note im deutsch test
bekommen
der pianist spielt ein lied mit schönen
noten der pianist spielt ein lied mit
schönen noten
der artikel der artikel der artikel in
der grammatik der artikel in der
grammatik der artikel in einer zeitung
der artikel in einer zeitung der artikel
steht vor dem substantiv der artikel
steht vor dem substantiv ein text in der
zeitung ist ein artikel ein text in der
zeitung ist ein artikel bei männlichen
substantiven benutzen wir den artikel
der bei männlichen substantiven benutzen
wir den artikel der bei weiblichen
substantiven benutzen wir den artikel
die bei weiblichen substantiven benutzen
wir den artikel die bei sächlichen
substantiven
benutzen wir den artikel das bei
sächlichen substantiven benutzen wir den
artikel dass ich lese einen
interessanten artikel
ich lese einen interessanten artikel
die erde die erde die erde für die
blumen die erde für die blumen die erde
als globus die erde als globus die
blumenerde die blumenerde die erde dreht
sich
die erde dreht sich die blumen wachsen
in der erde die blumen wachsen in der
erde
die erde ist ein planet
die erde ist ein planet das gericht das
gericht das gericht als gebäude das
gericht als gebäude das gericht als
essen das gericht als essen der richter
arbeitet im gericht
der richter arbeitet im gericht
das gericht ist eine mahlzeit
das gericht ist eine mahlzeit im gericht
wird ein fall verhandelt
im gericht wird ein fall verhandelt
heute esse ich ein leckeres gericht
heute esse ich ein leckeres gericht der
bei der bei der bald zum tanzen der ball
zum tanzen der ball zum spielen
der bald zum spielen
der ball ist ein fest zum tanzen
der ball ist ein fest zum tanzen ich
spiele mit dem basketball
ich spiele mit dem basketball der ball
mit masken ist ein masken bei der ball
mit masken ist ein maskenball die maske
die maske ich schlage den ball beim
baseball
ich schlage den ball beim baseball der
bauer
der bauer der bauer auf der farm der
bauer auf der farm der bauer auf dem
schachbrett
der bauer auf dem schachbrett der bauer
arbeitet auf dem bauernhof der bauer
bewegt sich auf dem schachbrett der
bauer bewegt sich auf dem schachbrett
der bauer fährt mit dem traktor der
bauer fährt mit dem traktor der bauer
schlägt den springer der bauer schlägt
den springer das blatt das blatt das
blatt papier das blatt papier das blatt
der pflanze das blatt der pflanze das
blatt zum schreiben das blatt zum
schreiben das blatt der pflanze ist grün
das blatt der pflanze ist grün
ich schreibe notizen auf das blatt ich
schreibe notizen auf das blatt
kennst du auch ein wort mit mehreren
bedeutungen abonniere den kanal der
halle deutsch schule und aktiviere das
kleine glöckchen gib uns jetzt einen
daumen nach oben und in dieser playlist
findest du weitere videos zum
deutschlernen klicke jetzt auf diese
playlist